Oh! Hello!
Ooooooh!
There's no one driving that.
Oh shit.
Mm-hmm
Oh!
Cool!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Hello Neighbor.
Now,
we still have our creep of a neighbor as you saw in that intro movie,
but this game has been...
...updated.
And even the developer said that the old version of the game was like,
a year old.
So this one is way more recent,
and offers a lot more in terms of actual legitimate gameplay.
And maybe have a little bit of story,
but also, why is there...?
Oh, it wasn't giant, I was just next to it.
HI!
Hidey-ho Neighborino!
You're lookin' good there with all your boarded up windows, and all your...
How did you put an upper deck that high?
I used to build decks for a living, that just doesn't seem practical.
So go-- what was that?
Oh.
I saw that!
The fuck was that?
Was that, like, a train car?
Do you have a roller coaster in your house?
So anyway, we've got uh-buh-duh-ejectives now,
We need to:
-Turn on the electricity,
-Check inside,
-Move stuff inside,
and then take a nap.
Which is exactly what I want to do with my life,
except I don't take naps.
You know what?
Before I do anything, I'm gonna go say "hi" to the neighbor.
OH!
I was not wrong!
What the fuck is that?
And also how do I build one of those in my house?
It seems awesome.
Oh! Hi!
Hello!
What are you doin' in your bathroom?
Why are you locked inside your own bathroom, buddy?
What are you doing there?
Ya havin' a good time?
You need any help?
Alright, you take care neighbor! I'll see ya around!
Alrighty then.
"Press E to activate."
Okay!
Haboosky!
uh
There we go!
HI!
Okay.
OOoo!
"Press F to pick up"
Okay!
Cool!
Ooh! "Left mouse button to use item"
*gasp* Coool!
Oh yes!
Uh...bah...Beh! Ok.
That key will be secure right there, no one's gonna break in, I'm...
...almost assured of that.
Can I go to-- Oo, hey, whaaat?
Why am I under the bed?
This doesn't seem like a thing that should happen.
Okie dokie then.
Oooh, I need to move stuff in, Don't I? Can I have my stuff, please?
Pretty please?
OH!
OOOH!
I'm strong as hell. Ok.
Uuumm... right here is good. *Blehing noises*
Ok. Chair, you handle all that material over there,  I'll bring the rest of this shit in.
*Mark noises* Right Here? *More Mark noises*
Ok. I... that--that's's good I guess?
*Even more Mark noises*
Ok, good enough.
Yaaaay!
I'm not even gonna close my front door. I'm not even gonna close this door.
Or shut the blinds! I'm just gonna go to sleep.
Aaaaah. Wha...
Wha--Did I sleep?
Am I--am I certain that I slept?
Alrighty, then.
*Exaggerated yawn* That was a good sleep, neighbor. Did you sleep well?
Oh, neighbor. Hi~.
Do you wanna be fre--what happened to all your boarded up windows?
That was a weird--whoa.
Ah. All the familiar sounds. What is that?
I got a hat. No on will ever notice me with my hat, apparently. Hello?
Ooooh, in the boiler room. Alrighty, then.
NEIGHBOR~.
I've just popped by for a visit.
Hello?
Oh, it's the bathroom that he likes so much.
Neighbor?
Alrighty, then. I FOUND YOUR HAT!
NEIGHBOR!
Ooh, hey. Oh, shit. Good God.
Oh, fuck that shit.
Ok, no one told me that THAT was going to be a part of this.
Eeugh.
Neighbor?
*Scary music starts* AAAAA 'KAY! NEIGHBOR!
Neighbor doesn't wanna play! Bye neighbor!
Byyyye! Ok.
Ah, ok.
I'm going upstairs, you can't stop me! Whoa.
HEY!
WHAT THE FUCK?!
WHY IS THERE A SHARK?! Whaaoooii.
Oh, ok.
Hi. Yeah--AGAIN. With the weird...
I don't know what that is! I don't know why that is--*Car crash noises*
WHAT THE FUCK?!
Oooooh, it's a portal to another dimension.
Oh, ok, you just freeze there, I'll--
I'm not paying attention at all, ok.
Well, that was bizarre.
My neighbor seems to be a bit of a son of a bitch.
His house seems to be a
endless loop of nightmares so let's go in it!
Barging right in. I'm not gonna jump into your god damn shark pit.
Like, holy shit. EH!
Uuugh, jeeze. Oh. It wants me real bad.
Can I throw this?
Bing bong!
Uh... Don't mind me. Hyup. AUGH! GOD. DAMMIT.
Alright, fine, then.
Alright, so if I take this box up with me, I should be able to hip-hop--
Oo.
Hello?
eeeeEEEEHH.
Ok.
HEY! AAAAAAAAAAAAA!
AAAAHH, FUCK!
Hellooooo.
Don't mind me--HEEEH
Ok...
HEEEH!
Ok.
So I just gotta...Ha-boo.
Ta--DON'T KNOCK MY BOX! I can't get really get a running...
Ah! AAAWWWW, COME ON! I'm gonna take both these boxes!
That's gonna help me!
And a trash can! And another trash can!
Ha-buh-eh--Ah, fuck! My...
My leeeegs are stuck in your God damn bullshit!
Oh, hi! Uh--
UUUUHHH, I'M STILL STUUCK!
I can't move!
AAH!
HI, NEIGHBOR!
Hi! Ok! Weird! Why did I get ker-punkled over there?
Bab-i-ty-boop. HA--Eh-oohh, ok. Hi!
He went the wrong way like an idiot. Ok.
So, if I go over here...
WhaeEEEHHH.
WHAT THE FUCK IS THIS?!
WHAT THE FUCK!
HUH.
HEY!
OH GOD HI! AAAH! FUCK!
*Sigh*
Oh, what the fuck is this?
I must be this tall to hiiide?
WHAT THE FUCK?!
What is this shit?!
Hellooo. Ah, ok! Alright.
Wha--okalrightAAH!
Ah.
Ok. Is it like a tutorial?
It's a tutorial isn't it? It's a tutorial.
It's a horrifying tutorial in this set of a theme park.
I hid! I hid effectively!
Ok, that didn't make any God damn sense at all... What the shit is up with this place here?
It's got an instruction thing--*Gasp of realization*
Wait a minute.
*Another gasp of realization* I need the bell!
Oh that's why I needed to go up there! *gasp* I need the bell!
*JUMPSCARE* AAAH! FFFFUCK!
Hrup!
Ok. Got the bell!
Ok, so I just gotta get back...
Soooooooooo...now!
Oh, COME--I'm not--no! It no do that!
Eee. Oh wha-- COME OOON! Aaaaaaah da da deh, just gotta hope he's not down staaairs.
He's not, ok. Goood dammit! That's not correct.
What did that do Ooh! I can use objects to--oooh!
That's good to know.
Oh, God, don't do that. Don't do that. Don't do that n--HEEEY! MY CHAAIR!
You sack of shit!
Hurup! Oh fu--OH FUCK OFF!
Uuuugh. FUCK you, got out of the way!
OH COME ON!
Aaaah, shit! Fuck you! Oh, Go--I put a trash can on my head and tried to hide!
Ok, don't knock my God damn trash cans please.
Heee--AH! Ah! Yes! Yeees! Yeees!
AHFUCKNOOOOOO COME OOOOOON!
Hah. Ok. Got it. Don't. Don't. STA--DUUUUDE, COME ON!
YOU ASSHOOOLE!
Ah! AAAAAAAAHHH!
Get it. Get it. Get it. Get it. Come on! Jesus Chri--NO! GOD DAMMIT FUCKING FUCK YOU!
Seriously! Just fuck off!
*Caught in a bear trap for the millionth time*
OOOOH, FUCK YOU!
Just get in the fuck damn water--OOHH, REALLY?
Goooood. *Whining and tantrum throwing.*
Ok. Aaaaaaugh--NOOOOO!
*More whining and tantrum throwing.*
OOOOH IT LET ME GET STUCK IN IT?!
IT STUCK ME IN IT?!
ARE YOU KIDDING MEEE?!
Well, alright. That's-- that's an option. This is--this is-- these are all options for things you could do.
OR
you could fucking behave yourself, and--uuugh.
Ok. Just let--let me. Oh! Yeeeees!
Yes! I'm outie! I'm out the front door!
I'm gonna go around the GOD DAMN BACK... with my GOD DAM BELL...
Aaaaand FUUUUUUUUUUCK YOOOOOOOOOOOOOU!
So now--what the hell?
Well, that doesn't seem natural.
Was i--has that always been there?
Ah, fucki--Hello!
Hi!
How are you?
Why are you up there?
What are you doing?
Is that another version of you?
How did you get there?
Are you enjoying your calisthenics? I think.
What the fuck--ok, he's gone. That's weird.
Ok! Yeah! Yeah! Ok!
*Small gasp.*
Ding.
OOOO!
OOOOO!
OOOOOO!
WHAT IS THAT?!
What is that? What is that? What am I looking at?
Oh! Hi! WHAT THE HELL?!
WHAT IS--WHAAAA I DIDN'T WANT THIS!
WAS THIS REALLY ALL THAT--?
WHY IS--WHY ARE THERE SO MANY MANNEQUINS?
THAT'S A BIG CONCERN OF MINE AND WHY IS THIS ONE HERE?
Do I need to bring this back to my house?
Oh, shit. Oh, shit.
Uuuh... sorry, I didn't mean to take your Grandma.
Take this, open this up, maybe?
Can I get out?
*gasp*
Ok...
So, I have no idea why this is here or why anything is... I'm gonna... get back to my place.
IIIIIII'm home freeeeeeeeeeee! And I got a mannequin with me.
And I got another chair, apparently. And a shovel.
Alright, I'll put you right--right there Oops, shit, sorry.
Meant to do that with a bit more grace. Whooah, ok, someone likes to party.
Hup bubity boo. Okie dokie, then.
Herbity ber berp. Can you just behave--
There we go! You're gonna keep a watchful eye on that damn neighbor of mine.
Ok!
WOOOOOOO!
I can't believe how long that fucking took!
But I did it. And I got this. Whatever the hell this is.
I dunno Maybe I'm trying to rescue everybody from being over there.
And when they come back to my home, they're gonna finally become normal human again...
Ooh. *gasp* What's that? *Gasp*
Oo. To the second floor.
YEESSS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S ON THE SECOND FLOOR BUT IT'S PROBABLY NO GOOD.
Oh, is he up here?
Oh, Go--Oh! Ok...
I bet he's over here, isn't he? Oh, shit he is.
I bet he is. Ok. I don't know where I am, that God damn this is so God damn loud.
Talking about the--
I don't know where he is.
He's nearby...
Hoh. Ah! Oo! This looks nice! I'm gonna push this big button!
Ok! I turned off the cameras I think?
*Scary music* AH! AAAAAAAAAH! WHAT THE FUCK?!
UAAAAAAAAH NOT GONNA BE HERE ANY MORE GOODBYE, GOODBYE, GOODBYE!
AAAAAAAAAGOODBYE!
Huuuuh, fuck.
I should have just jumped down into the... fruckin-frick-fruckin'...
The fruckin' other thing! I'm gonna hide under my bed until it's not time to hide under my bed.
No, don't sleep! No! Don't sleeeep!
Don't sleep you bitch! Did you sleep?!
Fuck you! God dammit! Ok, well, I didn't want to do that.
Uh, it just did that by itself, but I think I still got everything that I needed...
Uh, from before. The only problem is that he might have put more security measures in place.
Or maybe he didn't... 'cause he didn't catch me...so maybe that counts.
Just gonna go in the elevator...
Ok, that was definitely a new...
Come on.
What the--WHAT THE SHIT?!
OH COME OOON! Ugh, fucking....God dammit!
Why did you go to sleeeeeep?!
Maybe-Ah Whoa hey *so many "whoa"s*
Hey, come on, now.
Heh heh! Oh! *gasp* AH--deh--Fucking get back under there!
AAAWWW! But I know where the crowbar is now! And with the crowbar, I could open the exit door maybe?
WHY?! WHAT DID I DO?! Oh, come on, just get under there. Get under there.
*To the chase music* You don't know where I am, I am hidden.
Way too better than you can find no one will ever know where I--*Stops singing* Fuck you. I--GUAAAHHH!
That is such bullshit, ok? Hey dick weeeeed!
I mean, Neighbor!
Ok, that's open, I--I guess.
Really? Just--oh, it's just open! Ok! Well, then. Let me just get under here...
Grab a little bit of this ol' thing.
Hibity hoobity-- OH WHA--WHYYY?! GET OUT *Incomprehensible screeching* ARE YOU FUCKING KIDDING ME?!
Oh, fucking finaly!
WHERE'D MY CROWBAR GO?!
DID I THROW MY GOD DAMN CROWBAR?!
Did I not grab the God damn crowbar? Where the fuck did the crowbar go?
Are you fucking kidding me?
With this--OH, WHY IS IT THERE?
Fucking.... fucking... fuuuck? Maybe a little bit?
Fuck you! Oh really? ,Oh, you think that's gonna stop me? How 'bout no.
He didn't suspect a thing.
Now, I'm gonna use this hat to bash my way in there.
Ah. Yes. Hoo-ba-doo. Hoo-ba-da-booby.
There's still a lock on there, so I gotta find something to get the lock off.
And I bet that's on the second floor somehow! And that means I gotta build a staircase...
Straight up...
to the alcove on the outside and then I'll be able to get in there.
Oh, geezums. Ok, then.
Ooh, where did they go?
Welp, threw that away. Well, that did that. Well, ok, that's just not right.
That's
That's--I
I'm pretty sure that's probably not possible.
Oh, God, again with you.
This thing is a menace. Oh, so close!
Aw, come on! So close!
What? Wha--oh, why? Why?
Ok, so I learned a few things about this. I had to restart the game again because once again it was getting way too
Uh...overly complicated for me.
And, also, the lawn mower is just death on the ears, it's horrifying.
So, let me just-- *many "oh shit"s*
*Scary music* THAT'S NOT GOOD. AH FUCKING GOD DAMMIT THAT--
GAHAHA I'M SUCH AN ASSHOLE!
I KNEW I WAS IN DANGER, WHY DID I KEEP DOING IT?
Ok, so he's downstairs, now.
But this room is still locked off, so...
That's a problem.
But there's gotta be a key somewhere around here.
I just won't be able to get up there.
*Scary music* AH! God dammit! Ah! Fuck you! I'm getting out of here, bitch! AAAAAA COME ON!
JUST GO--OHFUCKINGFUUUUUUUUUUUUUUCK!
Once again it's God damn night.
Why?!
The only one out here! The only one!
Oh, fuck you. GOD!
FUCK A DUCK!
I'm assuming he's downstairs.
Oh, boy. Maybe I assumed wrong.
Ee. Ok. What's that? *Gasp*
Oo! Hey!
That's a thing!
Is this a lock pick maybe yes?
I think it is. But I also think I'm boned--I AM BONED.
AAAAAHHAHAHA!
AAAAAAAHA!
YEEEEEEE!
GET DOWN! GET THIS DOWN YES!
YES! YEEES! YEES!
Yes.
Ok, this is good. Why are you being a dick? No. No no no. No. No no--Ok. I slept
Ok.
Just in time for that to happen.
But, now...
I know for certain that I have a lock pick on me, so the only thing I need to do...
Is not die. I did tha--how did I not see that before?
Like, it could have been obvious, I just didn't look in that room besides all the colorful monitors.
Bright shining lights got the best of me. And then Markimoo was totally thwarted.
But not this time, because I have a lock of pick. I have apick of lock!
*excited noises*
Oooooh, it's-- Hey, what the hell?! Hi.
Ow!
Did you just body slam--Oh! Hey! W-wait a minute!
Uuuuh...
WHAT?!
WHA-THAT'S THE END?!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
HE JUST KILLS YOU--No, he doesn't kill you, he buries you ALIVE.
I think I reached the end, but that's something for you guys to experiment with. If you guys
wanna try that, maybe... there's two bells.
They're hard to get.
The one of them's hard to get, one's pretty easy.
But if you get the bell, then you get the shovel, then you get the other bell
The maybe it might work, but I have no idea. But I'll leave that up to you guys.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
And always, I will see you in the next video. Buh-bye!